yeah you shoot in my neighborhood I do I
live in West Harlem West Harlem there's
a nice homeless is true let's pound
Easter I still live in East Harlem in
West Harlem so I know both very well
Luke Cage you're filming season two what
can you tell us about the new season two
is wrapped I've been deaf for like a
month and a half now so I'm actually
sort of rested up now yeah so what can
we expect in season two listen we just
we just kind of like wrapped up the last
two episodes as for our soundtrack I
went into the the lab as like they call
it with Adrian young and Ali Ali Shaheed
Muhammad and Jo and the music is
excellent they do the scores with a live
orchestra this year it's going to be a
different season we know who we are now
is gonna be fast paced Luke is going
through a lot of changes there's a lot
of things happening he's changing as a
person and involving I can't wait for
people to see sort of where he's going
because it took a long time to get Luke
Cage up and ready and sort of getting
them engaged into his superhero mode so
I'm really happy about it and you
mentioned you mentioned the music music
factors prominently in this as well
Kendrick Lamar worked on this are you
looking forward to seeing that oh
absolutely
I mean when we we dropped I think people
were kind of nervous about letting music
sort of the kind of music that we were
gonna you know be promoting in our show
be at the forefront I think people have
embraced it now because I mean you like
Kendrick Lamar happy the entire run of a
film I mean I'm a big fan of his and I
know people are like upset last night
they didn't win a lot of stuff but you
know in my heart you know it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what he wins
the guy is a genius so I can't wait to
see it curious to what was it like you
know you did the solo Luke Cage then
defenders then you went back to a solo
season of Luke Cage what's it like going
back and forth from that group to that
is interesting not to mention that
started on Jessica Jones and I went to
Luke so a Luke Cage and then going back
to defenders as a group and then going
back to Luke Cage season two it's sort
of interesting because you sort of have
to you have to be like either play in
the sandbox as they say learn to play
with others in the sandbox and I think
I'm really good at that I can I can
recede into the background if I have to
and let someone else play the high note
and I can be the bass or I can do the
other way around so I'm having happy
either way so I think the second season
the people that really love Luke Cage
are really gonna really be excited about
this season because we really took it to
another level
everybody happy Super Bowl Sunday so
there's a bunch of trailers dropping we
got some new Luke Cage from the
himself he talks a little bit about
what's going on during the season and we
know from the set that we're gonna be
getting Heroes for Hire with Iron Fist
so I'll try to explain what's going on
with that but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos make sure you turn
alerts on so you don't miss anything
because there will be a bunch of
trailers dropping in the next couple of
days and then separately in the next
couple of weeks with like Deadpool to
the venom trailers gonna drop really
soon starting with the biggest thing
first obviously you heard him say that
Kendrick Lamar is working on their
soundtrack and music is such a big part
of the Luke Cage series he feels like
this is gonna be even better than season
one the music was probably one of the
best things about the series but the
other really important thing that he
says is that is completely different
totally from the first season he
confirms that they're not gonna spend
four episodes sitting on the stupid pops
just wondering whether or not he wants
to use his powers to make the world a
better place or make Harlem a better
place one of the biggest criticisms of
the Marvel Netflix series is that they
feel like there are six episodes worth
the story stretched out into 13 episodes
so it can feel like they're episodes
where just nothing is happening I think
that is why they chose to go full Heroes
for Hire with Danny red like they're
like okay people want Heroes for Hire
and we need to infuse more action into
our series well we can have Luke Cage
just go full linebacker on all these
criminals but we can also put iron fist
in there and just crank it up to 11
so timeline if you're wondering what's
going on with iron fist when this picks
up remember Colleen wings dojo is in
Harlem so regardless of what's going on
with the plot it would make sense the
Danny ran shows up to help him out he
put someone like that in a series and
there's got to be a lot of punching like
you don't put Danny ran the iron fist in
a series without letting him use the
iron fist
misty Knight also got her bionic arm
from Danny rands Hospital and she was
actually confirmed for iron fist season
2 which they're shooting right now Mike
Colter says they've been rapped on Luke
Cage season 2 for a long time now that
will probably drop at the end of the
summer the same way that defenders did
remember Jessica Jones season 2 is
dropping in March they've been shooting
daredevil season 3 for a while so just
given the amount of time it takes to
finish episodes we'll get Luke Cage
season 2 episodes next then at the end
of the year we'll get our daredevil
season 3 and I've already done a couple
videos about that the cast had been
talking about it so I'll post links to
that at the end of this some of the Luke
Cage season 2 villains that they've cast
are also a bit of a course correction
too so they have bushmaster in
nightshade which are both people from
the Power Man and Iron Fist team-up
comic books which is funny because
they're gonna be teaming up during the
series so it makes sense that they would
do villains from their team-up comic
book bushmaster is sort of like another
big gang leader they're just describing
him as a natural-born leader who's
looking for vengeance with his focus
that's solely on cages backyard of
Harlem then separately they're
describing the nightshade character as a
brilliant holistic doctor with a
mysterious past who's trying to make a
difference in Harlem any way she can so
she's a little bit more mysterious I
would say you know complicated black
Mariah's character is still like the
de-facto kingpin of the series she's the
real big bat but in the way that during
daredevil season 2 the kingpin was
locked up in jail
she's also probably on the DL but pretty
much anybody that did not die during
Luke Cage season 1 is coming back but do
not forget that his brother looked like
he was going to get juiced up just like
Luke Cage was so he'll go through the
same type of treatment and probably get
powered up so that he can be more of a
bull's-eye to Luke Cage as daredevil and
I know everybody wants to know if
bullseye is gonna come into the Marvel
Netflix series it's possible that he
shows
during daredevil season 3 but there
haven't been any casting announcements
if there are of course I'll do a video
for it
it almost looks like from the photos
that we've seen I mean they're using
them mostly for comedy like he has the
sweet xmas sweater on so obviously this
is gonna be hilarious because they're
both powerful enough to affect each
other like with the amount of Iron Fist
that Dany is able to harness at this
point it can get more powerful but at
his current power levels he can put Luke
Cage on his ass if he gets an open shot
and if Luke Cage can get close enough
and get his hands on Danny Rand he could
crush him like a soda can but it looks
like he's trying to teach Luke Cage
Kunlun martial arts and he just almost
not having it cool Black Panther fact he
adapted a lot of his eclectic fighting
technique from a bunch of different
martial arts part of that is the same
fighting style as Danny ran now he
doesn't have an iron fist but his
technology and the heart-shaped herb
give him the same power levels that you
would find in iron fist when he's not
completely activated I still think that
iron fist once he learns to fully
harnesses Qi can activate both of his
fists this sort of the way they tell you
visually on screen that he's become a
fully actualized iron fist is when both
fists light up that's when he becomes
the most powerful character on the
Marvel Netflix series but for now it's a
little more balanced between him and
Luke Cage but speaking of Super Bowl
Sunday Luke Cage would be like the
ultimate football player you could knock
him down and he's super strong so he
probably hooked that ball right out of
the stadium but like I said there's
gonna be a whole bunch of trailers
dropping tonight as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
all the uploads so also be posting on
Twitter and Facebook what the schedule
is gonna be so once we find out when
trailers are dropping I'll just start
doing the videos so everybody have a
really awesome night leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below click here for that daredevil
season 3 preview video and click here
for brand new Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you